[موسيقى]
اكثر من 300 كيلو متر قطعنا للوصول الى
جزيره
قرب الحدود الكنديه الامريكيه حيث يعيش
السكان الاصليون الذين يحاولون الحفاظ على
جذورهم وثقافتهم وبالطبع الحفاظ على هذه
الجذور له ثمن باهض
[موسيقى]
صور اسماعيل شمس
السكان الاصليون في جنوب اونتاريو لهم
ثقافتهم الفريده ولغتهم لم نتحدث لغه
واحده مجتمعات متعدده مثل بقيه الدول تكون
احيانا لديهم لغات متعدده ولديهم عاداتهم
اذا لدينا لغات المتعدده مثل بقيه دول
العالم مثلا في الصين هناك الصينيه
والمندرينيه والكوينيه لدينا ايضا لغتنا
وثقافتنا المتشابهه وعدتنا لكن في هذه
الجزيره اعتقد ان العادات تلاشت بسبب ما
حدث في المدارس الداخليه
امين
[موسيقى]
في هذه المهمه الخاصه نستكشف عادات
وتقاليد السكان الاصليين ونرفع اللثام عن
قصص محزنه واليما تعرض لها اطفال المدارس
الداخليه الذين لا تزال السلطات تبحث عن
بقايا جثتهم
[موسيقى]
عندما نرقص
لنا رقصتنا
ومجتمعنا من ضمن عاداتنا ان نجتمع مع
بعضنا لنرفع الصلوات من اجل الشفاء وليس
من الضروري ان نلتقط الصور اثناء الدعاء
الفستان الذي ارتديه تقليدي واسمه صوت
الغابه
احد ادويه الشفاء حيث يقال انه في الماضي
احد الرجال راى في منامه ان هذه الاصوات
تشفي ابنته لذلك فان مجتمعاتنا اعتادت على
ان هذه الاصوات هي الشفاء وعندما ترتفع
هذه الاصوات تعطي الشفاء والقوه